self-locating strings are um to do with
decimal places of irrational numbers so
we need a number with an infinitely long
decimal expansion
uh that is irrational of course so
we're basically going to do pi you
probably guess we're going with pi so
these are the first few digits of the
decimal expansion of pi and what we want
to do for these self-locating strings is
to label each position after the decimal
point so we're going to start with the
the first number so this is the first
position the second position the third
and then the question you ask yourself
to find a self-locating string is you
want the number to match its position
in the decimal expansion
so here we've got our first one straight
away the very first digit number one is
in the first place so that would be our
first self-locating string and then what
we want to do is continue along through
the numbers and see if we can find any
others of course the expansion is
infinite so we're going to hope that
there should be some more so if the
second number there had been a 2 that
would have worked as well but it's a 4
so exactly so if this was this would
need to be a 2 this would need to be a
three four five six seven so none of
these work yet
and the other thing is once we of course
get to double digit or triple digit
positions if we were for example
considering the twelfth number of the
decimal expansion we would need the 12th
position to be a 1 and then next to it
the 2. so you actually would need a 1 in
the 12th position and a 2 in the 13th
position if you think about that a
little bit you're probably they're sort
of most common near the beginning when
you just have one number that needs to
be in one fixed position and then when
you get to two digit three digit four
digit you have several requirements that
need to happen in a row so your
probability gets smaller so for position
one million you would need position one
million to be a one
and then the next six positions after
that to all be zero exactly so that's
very very unlikely let's be honest right
compared to just having let's say you
know a seven at position seven or
something if the numbers are truly
random which is generally what we assume
in the expansion of pi that each one
appears approximately equal probability
if that is indeed true then you know
you're going to see or expect to see
more of the lower down self-locating
digits compared to the higher up ones
further along we've got our first one to
a good start so what we now need to do
is
i need to write out more digits of pi um
so i'm going to have to load this up
i'll be honest that's about as good as
it gets for me because i'm knowing pi
what 3.14 seven decimal places you know
you don't really need more than seven
decimal places
[Music]
100
there we go the first 100 digits of pi
that was painful we've got our first
self-locating string here at position
one
and what we can now do is continue to
look through these numbers and without
even doing this i can already tell you
there aren't any more the next ones are
really really far away so after one
right at the very first digit we get our
self locating string it's super exciting
we think they're going to be really
common they're not
the next one is at sixteen thousand four
hundred and seventy so i'm definitely
not writing out sixteen thousand digits
of pi that that's that's a job for the
viewer and then after that we then jump
up to forty four thousand
eight hundred and ninety nine
then we go up to the big one at 79
million
873
884
so that's our first one in the very
first position then we go to our second
one at sixteen thousand the third one
forty four thousand and then the fourth
self-locating string at 79 million tom
would you guess that there are an
infinite number of these i'm i'm
inclined to say yes
with the idea being that
pi is an infinite string of decimals and
you you might expect that because it's
infinite you would hope that every
string of numbers should be in there at
some point but then you've got this
extra condition that not only does the
number have to appear it needs to appear
at a certain place so that's why these
are quite rare it's a difficult question
for sure it's a good question
all right but there's another way to
look at this there is indeed so and this
is the reason why i did write out the
first 100. so i'm going to take a
different color because
you may
have wondered why i labeled the first
position here the one as as index one
because you could also of course
completely
you know it could be completely valid to
label this as zero so if we call this
now the zeroth spot and then this one
the first and the second and of course
we continue in the same way we now have
a slightly different index we're going
to zero one two three four five six
bingo so we've got our first one
now at the sixth position
indexing from zero and then if we carry
on 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19
20. so there's a two in position 20 but
then there's a six so it doesn't work 21
22 23 24 25 26 27 we have a 2 and then
we've got a 7. so we've actually found
our second
self-locating string in positions 27 and
28. we've got six we've got 27 and then
we jump up to a number kind of near
sixteen thousand thirteen thousand five
hundred and ninety-eight
is our next third self-locating string
so it's not too far away from the
sixteen thousand on index one then we go
up to forty three thousand six hundred
and eleven
again maybe it's a coincidence maybe
it's not but it's quite similar to what
we saw before and then finally this one
is is less close but at least has the
same number of digits we get 24 million
643
510
and that is the final that's going to be
what five so we actually have one more
self-locating string
in the first 100 million digits of pi
when doing your indexing zero so as i
said there isn't a convention between
index zero or one but we're going to now
stick with index one from now on just
just to be clear
um and the perhaps more interesting
question about these it's super cool
finding them and you should totally go
away and try and find your own but the
other interesting thing you can do is
ask the question of do these things loop
back around on themselves so what i mean
by that is if i pick a starting point
for example
169. let's suppose it's my favorite
number well actually let's suppose it's
the favorite number of dan sikorski who
is the guy who found this out so this is
dan's favorite number
and what we do is we then look for well
where does the number 169 appear
in the decimal expansion of pi
and we should be able to spot it there
it is
169
is down here
and because i did this earlier this is
going to come in at position
40 starting here
so the number 169 so we've got 40th 41st
42nd
appears in position 40.
so now
you say we started with 169 and that has
sort of taken us to position 40 in the
expansion so then you say well now where
does 40 appear
in the expansion of pi so we're going to
try and create some kind of pathway
through this infinite decimal expansion
i imagine 40 appears all over the place
exactly so we're going to look for the
first occurrence of 40 that's sort of
the lowest down one that's the idea so
40 uh is going to appear at the 70th
position so the four's at 70 and the
zero is at 71. so we started at 169 40th
position we looked for 40 that's taken
us to the 70th position so now we look
for 70 that's the idea so 70 is coming
in right down the bottom and this is why
i wrote out 100 digits so 70 is down
here in position 96
is the starting number so we've gone 169
to 40 to 70
to 96 and now we're going to look for 96
and we're going to carry on and we're
going to see where we end up so 96 is
going to take us miles away to 180 then
we go this is a pretty long route we
then go through
3664.
then we look for that number which
appears in the 24
717 position then we go to 15492
then we go 84 198
so i think this is the highest point of
our path that we descend into the the
madness of the decimal expansion of pi
so that then goes back down to 65 489
3725 there is a point to this i promise
and we get to
16
9 7 4 41
7 0
2
3 7 8 8
5 7 5 7 19 58
14 609 six two
eight nine two forty four seven four
five and then we go to nine three eight
five and finally we get one six nine
again so we loop back round to one six
nine which appears in the 40th position
so the mathematical question here is
given any random starting number that we
just choose of any number of digits
do we always get a loop
[Music]
that's the the mathematical so it seems
like a bit of fun but there's like a
really deep mathematical question into
this do you always get
this loop that's going to happen given
any starting number will you always find
a loop the loop can be of any length it
could be very short it could be quite
long it could
but you know as long as it's not
infinite length
then you would loop back around and we
have no clue as far as i'm aware this is
just a sort of puzzling question um but
there is one thing that we can say
which is that
not every number
will have
an infinite loop because
this is where we come back to the
self-locating strings and my new
favorite thing at the moment because
if you end up at a self-locating string
so if you somehow come across
1 or 16 470
you don't move
because one is in position one so you
get to one and then you just loop back
around or you get to 16 470 and loop
back around so they're like dead ends or
they're basically dead ends so they're
so the self-locating strings stop these
loops from happening and i do have an
example of one loop which which
terminates at one if we start at 211 so
a random starting number this appears
actually back in here at position
here two one and then one down here so
annoyingly over two lines but we've got
our number here 211 and this is at
position 93.
this one here is the 93rd position so we
go 211 to 93. where does 93 appear
93.
ah but there's an earlier one oh hey
there this is good so you always go to
the earliest this is the the
it's just a rule it's an arbitrary rule
and you could change the rules but
for the purpose of our loops we're going
to the first appearance of that number
so so you're completely correct but this
is going to be the one and this is at
position 14
and now
where does 14 appear in pi i think you
know this one brady maybe
right at the beginning so 14 is in
position one so we've gone 211 to 93 to
and then we've gone to one and then we
just loop back around
forever and we're stuck at one so one
our self-locating string here is the
dead end you either have this big loop
that goes or you know some size of loop
where you just keep going around around
in circles you either reach your dead
end as you called it the self-locating
string which just circles back to itself
forever or
can we find a path and as again as far
as i'm aware no one has found such a
path where you just keep going forever
and ever and ever as far as i'm aware
there's no point to this this is i said
i found this on the pi search page it's
recreational maths but then it does lead
to quite a deep question the the
patterns of numbers within the expansion
of pi so whilst even if we were able to
answer that question
it probably wouldn't tell us much about
pi itself but the the methods and the
techniques you're going to use to do
such a proof
are going to probably be brand new and
lead to all kinds of other awesome stuff
it's like the classic case of you know
trying to climb a particular peak
there's not really that much at the peak
but it's everything all the other peaks
you scale to get to that one it's all
the other new stuff you discover then
has all these other amazing uses and
loads of really big results in maths
come from recreational playing around
with numbers this kind of thing
this is the first five million digits of
pie printed on 2 000 pieces of paper and
if you would like your very own piece of
pie i'm going to be signing these and
sending them out to number five viewers
to find out how to get one have a look
in the video description or go to
patreon.com
numberphile there's details there too
i better get started on this this is
gonna take a while
the motion of fluids crashing into each
other so we have two cases the reynolds
number we've got big reynolds number so
we say it's not just greater than one
it's much greater than one so sort of a
thousand and above turbulence
and your equations
so we've got rid now